[Aplausos]
[Música]
finlandia es un país famoso por tener la
mayor concentración de bandas de heavy
metal per cápita del mundo no esto no me
lo inventado alguien en internet se
dedicó a hacer un estudio con un mapa
incluido pero vamos a centrarnos en el
tema de hoy porque como os podéis
imaginar hoy no vamos a hablar de
finlandia por el heavy metal estas
semanas tanto suecia como finlandia
están en todos los medios de
comunicación por esta razón suecia y
finlandia solicitan formalmente y de la
mano su entrada en la otan y como os
podéis imaginar esto es todo un golpe
para rusia sobre todo en el caso de
finlandia de hecho si nos importa en
este vídeo vamos a poner más énfasis en
el caso de finlandia que en el de suecia
y la pregunta es por qué qué importancia
tienen frecia y finlandia para la otra a
fin de cuentas hablamos de dos países
con muy poca población suecia tiene poco
más de 10 millones de habitantes y
finlandia poco más de 5 millones y medio
porque es semejante desgracia para rusia
que entra en la otan que problemas
pueden encontrarse estos dos países por
el camino de verdad pueden llegar a
entrar en la otan y que puede hacer
rusia para evitarlo hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
pero antes de todo una pregunta alguna
vez has pensado cuánta deuda hay en todo
el mundo ojo que no es ninguna tontería
según el fondo monetario internacional y
el instituto de finanzas internacionales
y el mundo nunca ha estado tan endeudado
y lo que resulta aún más llamativo esta
vorágine de préstamos créditos y bonos
de todo tipo no para de crecer ahora
bien quienes son los responsables de
esta situación cuánta deuda hay
realmente en el mundo que puede suponer
esto para la economía mundial y tal vez
la pregunta más importante de todas
estamos acaso al borde de sufrir una
enorme crisis de deuda mundial pues
queridos amigos amigas si queréis
conocer la respuesta a todas estas
preguntas no os podéis perder el último
vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido el canal
de información financiera de mundo
activos con el que participamos os
dejamos el enlace en la descripción y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
la historia se repite
podríamos decir que ucrania es un déjà
vú de finlandia estos dos países tienen
tantos puntos en común que parece que
son la misma historia pero con distintos
personajes algo así como un remake al
igual que ucrania finlandia también
formó parte del imperio ruso en el año
1917 lograron la independencia sin
embargo en el año 1939 stalin decidió
invadir les iréis porque qué razones
tenían los rusos para invadir a los
pobres finlandeses cuál era la narrativa
del kremlin para justificar la guerra
contra finlandia pues atentos a este
póster de propaganda soviética
exacto es justo lo que parece un nazi
que está llevando un perrito con una
correa evidentemente el perrito es una
alegoría de finlandia de hecho no sé si
entendéis bien el texto supongo que no
porque no entenderéis ruso pero dice la
dra el perro fascista habéis oído bien
según stalin rusia tenía que conquistar
finlandia para des nacif y carla así es
como estalló la llamada guerra de
invierno una guerra que rusia esperaba
ganar en pocas semanas lorgio soviéticas
superaba finlandia en todos los frentes
tenían más soldados mejores armas y más
dinero sin embargo los finlandeses
opusieron resistencia
conocía mucho mejor el terno y sabían
resistir el frío mucho mejor que nadie
desde entonces finlandia todavía tiene
regimientos enteros de soldados
esquiadores
en esta guerra es donde se forjaron
leyendas como simón
más conocido como la muerte blanca se
trata del francotirador más mortífero de
la historia quinientas cinco muertes
confirmadas tras 100 días de guerra en
las condiciones más extremas que os
podrías imaginar rusia se retiró
seguramente muchos ya conozcáis esta
historia lo que no se suele contar es
que finlandia no ganó la guerra al menos
no fue una victoria rotunda aparte del
coste humano y de todos los destrozos de
la guerra finlandia tuvo que pagar 300
millones de dólares a rusia como
reparación para que os hagáis una idea
eso serían como 5 mil 780 millones de
dólares de hoy en día además rusia se
quedó con un par de regiones en el norte
de finlandia y con buena parte de
karelia y la pregunta que muchos
estaréis haciendo es mereció la pena
hizo bien finlandia en plantarle cara a
rusia o tal vez habría sido mejor
ahorrarse la guerra la respuesta no
podía ser más rotunda si hicieron bien y
los datos hablan por sí solos
a día de hoy los finlandeses disfrutan
de un peine per cápita de 49 mil dólares
la república de karelia no llega a siete
mil ciento setenta dólares esperanza de
vida en finlandia es de 81 años en rusia
es de 73 es igualdad finlandia es uno de
los países más igualitarios del mundo
con un coeficiente de gini de 27 7
puntos rusia por el contrario es
muchísimo más desigual con un
coeficiente de gini de 35,3 en otras
palabras que da igual el indicador que
miremos finlandia está entre las mejores
posiciones del mundo y rusia entre las
peores probablemente los pobres
canadienses que están en la frontera con
finlandia se están preguntando todos los
días porque esos antepasados no
consiguieron que la frontera se moviera
un poquito más hacia el este de hecho da
la casualidad de que la república de
karelia es una de las regiones con menos
apoyo al partido de putin aunque
evidentemente eso importa poco en la
democracia rusa dicho de otra manera hay
pocos ejemplos donde una frontera marca
una diferencia tan grande en la vida de
los ciudadanos pero ahora la pregunta
que os estaréis haciendo todos es por
qué es tan importante que finlandia y
suecia se unan a la otan que aportan
exactamente a la alianza es simplemente
un movimiento simbólico
hay algo más ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
no querías otan pues toma nota
final de y suecia son dos de los países
más difíciles de invadir del mundo son
dos ejemplos de lo que podríamos llamar
seguridad total es decir que toda la
sociedad está preparada para una
invasión desde civiles hasta militares
para que sabes la idea suecia tiene más
de 65 mil refugios para caso de guerra
de hecho en algunas regiones suecas es
obligatorio que todas las casas tengan
su propio búnker solo en helsinki la
capital de finlandia hay más de 5500
búnkeres además tanto finlandia como
suecia tienen ejércitos bien armados y
perfectamente adaptados a las exigencias
de la otan
pero hay algo mucho más importante que
todo eso la gran aportación de finlandia
y de suecia la otan es la geografía
atentos a este mapa
[Música]
aquí podéis ver el mar báltico finlandia
y estonia controlan toda la salida de
rusia al báltico desde san petesburgo
estonia ya está en la otan si finlandia
entra la otan podría cerrar el tráfico
de los barcos rusos que salen de san
petesburgo y diréis vale bien pero rusia
todavía tiene una salida al báltico
kaliningrado sin embargo espera un
momento porque justo enfrente de
kaliningrado está suecia que también
está a punto de entrar en la otra
[Música]
suecia también tiene esta isla que veis
aquí la isla de gotland hasta hace meses
esta isla estaba desmilitarizada pero
suecia ya ha enviado tropas y desde ahí
puede controlar toda esta zona del
báltico conclusión rusia quería evitar
tener a la otan en su frontera ahora va
a estar rodeada de la otan en el único
punto por donde pueden salir al
atlántico si quiero enfrentar un
submarino con cabezas nucleares por
ejemplo es casi imposible que no lo
detecte un radar pensad que todos los
ejércitos de la otan comparten
información
[Música]
y ya sé lo qué pensaréis muchos pero de
verdad es tan importante el mar báltico
para rusia técnicamente también tienen
acceso al mar negro y el mar negro
también es un mar de aguas calientes el
problema fijaos en este otro mapa
[Música]
si os fijáis veréis que la única salida
del mar negro hacia el mar mediterráneo
es el estrecho del bósforo que está en
turquía y si turquía también está en la
otan de hecho de otra manera rusia
podría estar a punto de perder todo el
control de todas sus salidas al mar al
menos en la parte occidental pero no
sólo eso fijaos en este otro mapa
[Música]
éste saliente que veis aquí en la parte
rusa es la península de kola se estima
que esta es la zona con mayor densidad
de silos nucleares del mundo aquí es
donde rusia tendría casi todas sus
cabezas nucleares y sus bases de
aviación según caspian report todas
estas bases militares están conectadas
por una única línea de ferrocarril
habéis oído bien te estamos diciendo que
la mayor parte del arsenal nuclear ruso
estaría conectado por una única línea de
tren esto qué significa pues que
bastaría con un ataque bien orquestado y
todas las líneas de logística que
alimentan ese arsenal nuclear colapsaría
hasta ahora nada de esto era un problema
para rusia los únicos que podrían
sabotear esta línea de ferrocarril
serían los finlandeses pero recordad que
finlandia no estaba en la otan sin
embargo todo esto está a punto de
cambiar así que ya os podéis imaginar lo
que todo esto supone para russian
paréntesis esto no significa que rusia
perdería todas sus bombas nucleares pero
está claro que sería más difícil para el
kremlin poder echar mano de todo ese
arsenal nuclear dicho de otra manera que
finlandia en la otan es algo que rusia
no se puede permitir la pregunta es qué
pueden hacer para evitarlo pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
demasiado tarde para actuar
[Música]
cuántas veces habéis oído hablar en los
últimos meses del concepto de la
expansión de la otan según la narrativa
rusa la otan es como una especie de
mancha de aceite que va tomando nuevos
países sin embargo como estamos viendo
en este caso no es lado está en quien se
expande es que son los países que se
sienten amenazados por rusia los que
buscan protección ahora bien entrar en
la otan no es un proceso automático
desde que un país solicita su entrada
hasta que finalmente entra hay un
periodo que puede durar entre varios
meses incluso más de un año donde es
especialmente débil pensando bien una
vez suecia y finlandia entrarán en la
otan rusia ya no podría atacar les
porque pues porque sería un ataque
contra la otan en su conjunto sin
embargo hasta que eso ocurra rusia
podría por ejemplo lanzar pequeños
ataques sin que la otan estuviera
obligada a responder y eso explica
amenazas cómo está rusia amenaza con
repensar las técnicas y militares por la
entrada de finlandia en la otan y diréis
pero que puede hacer rusia
[Música]
en principio podría lanzar misiles de
crucero a ciertos sitios estratégicos en
finlandia y suecia podrían destruir
centrales eléctricas torres de
comunicaciones y colapsar toda su
economía sino apoyo de la otan finlandia
difícilmente podría responder o tal vez
sí atentos reino unido- lanza un nuevo
acuerdo de seguridad con suecia y
finlandia habéis oído bien boris johnson
ha sido más rápido que la propia otan
antes de que el resto de países miembros
decidan si aceptan a finlandia suecia
reino unido ya ha prometido cooperación
militar qué significa esto pues que si
moscú ataca londres responde y recordad
que reinó unido- si tiene armas
nucleares pero no sólo eso después del
movimiento de reino unido otros países
han seguido la estela después llegó
polonia y después ha llegado eeuu
conclusión la ventana de oportunidad
para rusia se ha cerrado
aunque final de y suecia no estén en la
otan todavía ya tienen el apoyo de dos
potencias nucleares pueden atacar con
medidas económicas por supuesto de hecho
el kremlin ya ha anunciado que cortará
todo el suministro de gas a finlandia y
esto es un problema pero desde el punto
de vista militar cada vez tienen menos
opciones y eso explica que días después
de amenazar con tantísimas represalias
el discurso de moscú haya cambiado
radicalmente
atentos el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de rusia serguéi lávrov dice
que la entrada de suecia y finlandia en
la otan no marca una gran diferencia
habéis oído bien no marca una gran
diferencia y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando entonces si rusia no puede
hacer nada entonces es cuestión de
tiempo que finlandia entra en la otan
verdad es posible que algo salga mal
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
y
tiempo de negociaciones
en príncipe la otan tiene una política
de puertas abiertas es decir que tanto
finlandia como suecia podrían entrar sin
ningún problema ahora bien todos los
países miembros tienen que aceptarlo
todos sin excepción y diréis que países
querrían vetar la entrada de suecia y
finlandia en la otan pues principalmente
2 hungría y turquía principalmente
turquía atentos la turquía de erdogán
relación a la entrada de suecia y
finlandia en la otan con que devuelvan a
los terroristas los que estáis suscritos
a nuestro boletín semanal de patrón ya
lo conocéis turquía lleva años luchando
contra la minoría kurda turquía tiene a
varias organizaciones kurdas en su lista
de grupos terroristas sin embargo tanto
suecia como finlandia han dado asilo
político a miembros de estas
organizaciones concretamente estos dos
países se han negado a extraditar a 33
individuos según turquía
esto implica colaborar con terroristas y
no están dispuestos a aceptar la entrada
de suecia y finlandia hasta que no
colaboren en su lucha contra lo que
ellos llaman el terrorismo kurdo pero no
sólo hablamos de kurdos según erdogán
también se incluye una lista de grupos
terroristas a los seguidores de tula
cullen si recordáis petula gülen es uno
de los enemigos políticos de erdogán y
uno de los principales instigadores del
golpe de estado del año 2016
[Aplausos]
la pregunta es de verdad esta es la
única razón pues es muy probable que no
os lo hemos contado varias veces aquí en
visual polític turquía es el enfant
terrible de la otan y eso significa que
eeuu les ha vetado de la compra de
muchas armas por ejemplo turquía no
puede comprar f-35 sin embargo ahora
pueden utilizar este poder de veto para
renegociar y por el momento está dando
resultados atentos turquía confirma que
reinó unido- ha levantado el embargo en
las exportaciones de material de defensa
y diréis pues ya está la otan volverá a
vender armas a turquía como si no
hubiera pasado nada y a cambio turquía
aceptará a suecia y finlandia
asunto resuelto verdad pues no es tan
sencillo de nuevo a turquía es el niño
problemático de la otan porque pues
entre otras muchas cosas por su eterna
animadversión con otro miembro de la
otan
grecia es muy probable que grecia no
esté muy contenta si su principal
antagonista vuelve a tener acceso al
arsenal militar de última generación de
los eeuu y todavía está en el aire otra
pregunta hasta qué punto hungría puede
esta nueva expansión de la otan de
verdad va a ser posible solucionar todas
estas diferencias
[Música]
una cosa está clara salvo turquía y
hungría parece que todos los demás
miembros están más que decididos a
aceptar a estos nuevos países la
pregunta es cómo van a conseguir
convencer a hungría y a turquía de
verdad suecia y finlandia van a terminar
entrando en la otan existe alguna forma
de que rusia lo consigue evitar veremos
una campaña de propaganda masiva para
intentar convencernos a los europeos de
que finlandia y suecia son países
dominados por los nazis podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que aquí en
visual político sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribe a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones recordad también que
podéis apoyarnos en patrio ni accederéis
a nuestra newsletter contenido exclusivo
y merchandising si se ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]